yes there's hope for the new Macbook
Pros coming out here in the next couple
of months because we just got a brand
new updated leak showing that not all
hope is lost yes we're finally getting
better performance with single core so
much more that we might actually be
seeing four nanometer or maybe three
nanometer chips and I'm gonna explain in
this video and show you guys the map so
check this out we just got the new
geekbench scores of these new Macbook
Pros as you can see someone tweeted
right here
2027 single core score and 14
888 Yes we finally broke the 2 000
single core barrier on Apple silicon the
previous leaks they showed pretty bad
scores as you can see 1889 which is even
worse than the M2 Chip which to me
didn't really make sense but now with
the new one over 2 000 points that
actually makes me feel a lot better
whether or not it's actually going to be
five nanometer four nanometer maybe
three nanometer I don't know this makes
me feel a lot better now the interesting
thing about this leaked Benchmark
compared to the other ones is that the
base frequency is now
3.68 gigahertz so that means this one is
clocked even higher than the previous M2
Max models which were 3.54 so I don't
know what change happened here maybe
this was a prototype and then this one
is clocked even higher on the same five
nanometer maybe or maybe even it's
actually upgraded for nanometer from the
a16 chip or on the other hand maybe it's
because of this being a beta build as
you can see Mac OS 13.2 that's actually
not out yet so what if we're gonna see
even more improved scores over time even
higher than this now what I do want to
mention is that a lot of people thought
that these leaks were completely faked
like somebody created some system fake
these leaks however I actually he went
and did a ton of math and I confirmed
that the math actually does check out so
look what I did here I took the M2 Chip
performance I split up the performance
between what we have from the multi-core
and the single core and I found that we
get about 7 700 points from the
performance cores alone and
304.75 from each E chord then I did the
same thing for the M1 ship then I added
the math over to the M1 Pro and I saw
that the performance cores actually have
some efficiency loss 9.5 loss and
performance core performance when you go
up to six P cores then I went to the
unbend tan core model where it goes up
to a 14
loss with every performance core when
you go up to eight performance cores and
now I made the theoretical math for the
M2 Max leaks now I looked at the
original one that we had last week with
a 12 core setup where we have the same 8
perform his cores but now for efficiency
instead of two and I'm going to talk
about the implications of that in just a
minute but I added everything up I did
the math I added in the 14 performance
loss as you can see right here I looked
at the performance per each performance
core with that loss added in and finally
we got 14 215 multi-core points which
checks out right there close to the
multi-core score that we saw in the leak
last week but now with the new leaks I
did it again with the updated scores as
you can see 2027 per each core I added
in the performance loss of 14 I added it
all up as you can see right here and I
ended up with 15
165 multi-core points which is right
there only a couple hundred points off
from the actual leaked Benchmark which
is
1488 so that's within a margin of
difference so we could actually see
fifteen thousand multi-core scores and
the math of course checks out so
honestly I don't think that these leaked
benchmarks are fake I think they
actually are legit and they check out
but now the key point that we have to
evaluate is of course the 3.68 gigahertz
base frequency which is very very unique
because if you look at the frequency of
the M2 Chip the highest clock speed or
gigahertz per core is 3.5 with a single
core but for some reason this leak shows
3.68 so Apple obviously clocked it
higher now the question is why did they
clock it higher because if you go back
and you look at all of the M1 family of
chimps starting with the original
regular M1 it was clocked at 3.2 then if
you look at the M1 Pro also 3.2 cap in
terms of the single core clock speed
then and when Max 3.2 then M1 Ultra in
the Mac Studio also 3.2 so Apple decided
to Cap all of them hard cap at 3.2
gigahertz I think it's because it's part
of the same family Apple wanted to cap
it across the board in terms of single
core performance probably so that when
the M2 family comes out it all looks
like it's faster and better however the
weird thing is that the M2 is 3.5 which
makes sense so I assumed the entire M2
family would be 3.5 as well but this new
leak is 3.68 so what if the M2 Pro and
M2 Max is actually on a different
process node technology not the same
five nanometer but potentially four
nanometer or even three nanometer and
that's actually what I cave Dave on
Twitter assumed might actually happen
because as soon as he saw the updated
Leak with over 2000 single Court he said
hey it might actually be three nanometer
this time around because of that high
score due to of course the higher 3.68
gigahertz clock speed but now regardless
of which process note it ends up being
on I do want to make a point about the
12 core M2 Max ship and that it's going
to have eight performance cores which is
unchanged but now it's going to have
double the efficiency cores four instead
of two and that is going to mean some
actually nice improvements for you
because battery life is gonna improve
one of the reasons why these higher end
14 and 16 inch MacBook Pros didn't get
the same really good battery life as the
M1 and the M2 MacBook Air was because
they only have two efficiency cores
which means that they have to rely more
on the performance cores which eat more
power but now they're on an even playing
field with four efficiency cores both on
the M2 Chip regular and the M2 Pro and
M2 Max so that is going to improve
because they're going to be able to
handle more tasks by themselves without
having to access those performance cores
so that's going to be a benefit
regardless if we stay on five nanometer
or even go to four or three but now
here's the problem with five nanometer
even though this new leak has over 2 000
single core score almost 15 000
multi-core check this out this is
Intel's new I9
13900hx which is a mobile chip that's
going to be going into those big laptops
look it beats it out in every way faster
single core and much faster multi-core
but now with that said let's actually
delve into the graphics performance that
we could see on the M2 Max and I
actually ran some calculations that I'm
gonna go through but first I want to
show you an updated geekbench 5 metal
test that we just ran on the M1 Max 71
288
eight points which is pretty good and
that's going to be our Baseline for
these calculations that we're about to
do now here's how I figured out the
graphics performance I took the M2 Chip
compared to the M1 which the M1 had 21
and a half thousand metal score and the
M2 had 30
842 so that's a pretty good difference
however you have to keep in mind that
the M1 had an 8 core GPU the M2 has a 10
core which is 25
more cores so if we add 25 percent to
the score of the M1 which is 21.5 times
25 that gives us 26
905 points now with theoretically the
same 10 cores now that we added that 25
in the M2 Chip is now only 15 faster
than the 10 core theoretical M1 which is
the actual architectural gain with no
difference in course so really going
from M1 to M2 technology 15 faster so
now let's apply that same thing to the
M2 Max ship according to Mark German he
believes that the M2 Max is going to
have 38 GPU cores compared to the 32
that we have with the current M1 Max so
now going from the 32 core M1 Max to 38
that's
18.75 percent more cores not 25 more
like we had with the regular M2 Chip
because it had a lower number of cores
so the difference is bigger so if we
take the M1 Max's score that we have
right now 71 000 288 then add 18.75 to
account for the core difference going up
to 38 cores we now have 84 654 metal
score then we go in and add the 15
architectural Improvement gain assuming
it's on the same five nanometer as the
M2 and we're left with 97 000 metal All
Points which is getting pretty close to
a hundred thousand which is actually
decent and that leaves us with a score
that's 36.5 faster than the 32 core M1
Max and that's actually not that bad now
that I think about it even on five
nanometers so what if Apple can get away
with five nanometer again it's a
disappointing upgrade for US tech
enthusiasts but for the basic person
they're not even going to know what's
going on with five nanometer versus
potential three nanometer they're just
gonna see it and buy it they're gonna
see that it's faster they're going to
look at Apple's marketing hey 36 faster
this time around they're gonna buy it
and for Apple it could make sense to
delay the real Three nanometer upgrade
for another year and a half while we go
through this recession because people
might not be buying them anyway so the
question we have now is do we wait for
this M2 Max or do we just buy the
current ones we have now that are
already really good at video editing
photo editing Pro programming they're
already good so do you justify waiting
and spending potentially more for the
new M2 Max or just buy one of these on
sale right now which you can do using
the YouTube product tagging feature just
click that link right there you could
definitely do that so let me know your
thoughts on this down in the comment
section below and click the circle above
to subscribe for more videos like this
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video
[Music]